connaissez-vous la pari d'owlient c'est
une sorte d'illusion d'optique et c'est
la spécialité de farid saadi dans
certaines de ses toiles se cachent des
femmes ou des couples il faut prendre le
temps de les découvrir
hier il y avait une dame qui restait sur
un des tableaux qui restés pendant plus
d'un quart d'heure qui adore ce tableau
qui a qui a dicté sa loi toucher
vraiment mais qui n'avait jamais vu
qu'il y avait une femme là je lui dis à
la fin l'artiste drouet aime faire
voyager le public dans son univers
surréaliste
sa technique et son imaginaire ont
bluffé les organisateurs du salon
ils l'ont donc choisi pour invité
d'honneur il ya une part de vrai et
payer une part de rêve donc la part de
rêve elle est importante
la part de séduction le jeu est aussi
appréciée à marthe nom pierre un
concours est organisé dans le cadre du
salon concours de portraits
ça nous donne l'occasion d'admirer la
joconde de près sur la mienne j'ai à peu
près entre chant 50 et 200 couche de
peinture pour que et j'ai attendu sept
ans pour qu'elle tourne les yeux un
travail colossal une peinture à l'huile
exigeante alors compensons avec ses
oeuvres réalisées avec aisance en
quelques secondes
cet artiste de lure et anime des
démonstrations de dessins à l'encré pour
faire une démonstration c'est très
pratique parce que j'ai pas besoin de
beaucoup matériel ma bouteille d'encre
mais plumes au calame et puis ça me
suffit et le papier et voilà j'ai pas
besoin de beaucoup d espace et voilà on
peut aussi se saisir de son cas là mais
de ses encres pour tenter de réaliser à
notre tour d silhouette toute en
légèreté